música
[Música]
bienvenidos a un nuevo capítulo de
historia
soy andrés suárez jaramillo colombia
protagoniza un paro nacional histórico
desde el 28 de abril de 2021 se han
desarrollado días de masivas
movilizaciones que comenzaron en contra
de una reforma tributaria pero que
escalaron a la exigencia de una serie de
cambios políticos contra la corrupción
la pobreza la desigualdad el respeto a
los acuerdos de paz entre múltiples
otras demandas que también incluyen una
reforma a la policía ya las fuerzas
armadas luego de la violenta represión
con la que el estado colombiano ha
respondido a la protesta y que ha dejado
decenas de muertos en cuestión de días
para explorar los antecedentes del paro
y de las protestas sociales en colombia
vamos a hablar con mauricio archila él
es doctor en historia de la universidad
estatal de nueva york y como
investigador del cinep el centro de
investigaciones y de educación popular
en colombia ha registrado junto con su
equipo más de 25 mil protestas desde
hasta la fecha profesor un gusto que
esté con nosotros había ocurrido en la
historia de colombia un paro nacional
semejante al que actualmente estamos
viviendo los colombianos
si ha habido antecedentes en el 77 en el
2013 2019 el 21n pero eran paros o bien
muy urbanos
básicamente rurales este es inédito en
el sentido de que tiene mucha gente en
campo y ciudad y se ha prolongado por 10
días profesor hablemos del gran paro
cívico de 1977 el que por más de 40 años
se consideraba el más grande y violento
de colombia con cerca de 20 muertos en
apenas una jornada porque momento
atravesaba colombia en la década de 1970
para que confluyeran los sindicatos en
contra de las políticas del entonces
presidente alfonso lópez michelsen
el desmonte del régimen bipartidista
cerrado que se llama frente nacional el
primer gobierno post treintena nacional
tenía una obra reformista su padre
alfonso lópez había sido el gran
reformista de la primera mitad del siglo
lópez michelsen como tal más que
reformista termino siendo como una
especie de proto neoliberal
políticas de apertura
desindustrialización privatizaciones y
un costo de vida impresionante así entré
básicamente eso produjo una gran
movilización de sectores sindicales
campesinos indígenas estudiantiles la
arrogancia con que el gobierno trató
también la del paro fue una de las
causas que produjo su agudización como
influyó la arrogancia el presidente de
la época justamente de quién estamos
hablando alfonso lópez michelsen la
arrogancia pues yo creo que marcó mucho
el desenlace de la protesta
los sindicatos más de izquierda
podríamos decir pero los que plantearon
primero la posibilidad de paro y luego
se sumaron los más cercanos al gobierno
lo que se desconoció la legitimidad del
pliego de peticiones se negó a hablar
con los dirigentes sindicales y pues
trató de minimizar siempre la protesta
incluso hasta cuando ocurrió cuando
ocurrió pues salió por la noche y mostró
unas tachuelas unas respondía unos
artefactos de éstos para pinchar ruedas
para vender taponar el transporte y
bueno le echó la culpa porque un sector
conservador que se sumó al paro aunque
fue básicamente la izquierda y el centro
pues llamamos social y político y le
echó la culpa al que es que a los
jesuitas y al baaz un sector conservador
que siempre con una ironía se gastaba
una ironía expresión a la protesta y a
los líderes que le exigían entonces al
gobierno los sindicatos y otros sectores
de la sociedad que se sumaron a aquel
paro pues en ese momento básicamente
eran reivindicaciones de carácter
económico como freno al costo de vida
aumentos salariales reforma agraria
reforma urbana
básicamente eso plata para el dinero es
para la educación pública y tal vez se
había allí una idea de más apertura
democrática él estaba moviendo una
constituyente que le llamaron la pequeña
constituyente y la gente se oponía
también a eso pero eran básicamente
reivindicaciones de corte material y
político volvamos al presente cómo
evalúa el actual paro nacional qué
opiniones le merece cree que se está
marcando un hito yo sé creo sí creo es
un gobierno tv
es un gobierno que se ha militarizado
que se apoya en los militares en una
militarización de la policía que
desprecia y desconoce el carácter
político de la protesta la atribuye a
los llamados vándalos que no son sino
simplemente gente que protesta
obviamente con condiciones muy radicales
y creo que hay una serie de factores que
vienen acumulados históricamente incluso
que no corresponden a este gobierno pero
que en este gobierno que se ha negado a
cumplir los acuerdos de paz y otros
acuerdos y que ha tratado de imponer una
reforma tributaria a todas luces injusta
desacertada en el periodo en el momento
en que estamos eso hizo que se rebosará
la copa
muchas gracias mauricio archila por esta
entrevista para la crónica de historia
él es profesor de la universidad
nacional e investigador del cinep en
colombia a ustedes gracias por compartir
y comentar estas historias que las
encuentran en los programas de france 24
punto com
[Música]